631 right now the country is watching
nevada we are one of five
states that are still too close to call
this morning thanks for being with us
everyone
i'm alex backus i'm john langler of
course we're talking about the race for
the white house let's look at the
numbers
as we stand here joe biden here in
nevada leads president trump by about 7
600 votes
nevada though is going to release new
vote totals later this morning at about
nine
now shortly before six this morning the
president tweeted this
quite simply stop the count
this as we learned the trump campaign is
holding a press conference here in las
vegas this morning
we understand that's happening at 8 30.
just ahead of getting those updated
results at 9 00. they will be the first
results we have gotten since yesterday
morning so with more on this
let's go over to hector mejia he is live
with more good morning hector
taylor good morning and it's definitely
taken a lot longer than any one of us
would like but the county here says
one they're still counting and two they
want to get it right
this morning we're finally getting new
numbers for the first time in 24 hours
from both the county and the state
and with the race being so close that
update will give us a better picture in
the race for the white house
the state's six electoral votes could be
what joe biden needs to
reach 270. biden leads president donald
trump here in nevada by a thin
7 600 votes the secretary of state for
election
says there are ballots in the mail
stream that are still working their way
through
into the building right behind us where
we're at live this morning
mail ballots can be counted up to a week
after the election
as long as they were postmarked by
election day
registrar voters joe gloria told us all
early and all election day votes have
already been counted
and this morning there's more than just
mail ballots left to count
provisional ballots electronic ballots
that were sent to overseas voters
electronic ballots that were processed
for disabled voters
and also some special ballots for new
residents
so a lot will be happening here
throughout the day at our local
elections department we have media from
around the country here this morning
the county says it can count up to 70
000
ballots a day workers are opening mail
ballots checking signatures scanning
them
while we're learning new numbers this
morning it could take several days for
final results to be released so again at
8 30 this morning the trump campaign
will be holding a press conference here
at nine o'clock this morning the state
will provide new numbers and then at 10
o'clock this morning
that is when we will receive an update
from the county on their efforts here as
they continue
counting mail ballots here in the
building right behind us reporting live
from north las vegas hector mejia
8 news now